I kind of want to see Colleen do an  imitation of Joe watch this [ __ ] are you  ready  that's when Bart's telling a story and  then Joe's like thinking about somebody  except for Joe there's literally  he's like so this red car crashed into  the wall what color was the card game or  even this thing you just met that girl I  didn't know yeah oh you just met her yes  I just met her at the DMV it's all the  same day I missed that point when I have  to edit the reels I always have to cut  away from him because he's just going  like this  leverage they're they're the ones that  uh have the middle guy by the balls they  technically didn't do anything because  from their angle the person who chose  the sublease whether it was legal or not  was offering them something I just want  to know like what's he thinking about  like this red car crashed to walk they'd  be like I never had a father